il fut un temps aux prémices du monde
[Musique]
où le soleil ne s'était jamais levé
mais même en ce temps là
une lumière rayonnait
quant au micro retourne ce mot
ouais
[Musique]
les elfes ont des forêts à protéger
les nains gardent leurs mines
les hommes leurs champs de céréales mais
les pieds de l'ue n'ont pas à
s'inquiéter tant qu restants
[Musique]
on est en sécurité
vous avez assez combattu et galadriel
rangez votre épée
l'ennemi est toujours là reste à savoir
où ils se cachent
cette quête est révolue mais vous n'avez
pas vu ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui fut
bien assez
vous n'avez pas vu
ce que moi j'ai vu
[Musique]
les ténèbres envahiront la terre toute
entière
ce sera la fin tu pour non seulement du
pas traiter self
mais aussi de tous les peuples
[Musique]
je suis désolé mais l'heure a sonné
passé toujours avec nous
le passé est révolu
soit nous avançons
soit nous en restons prisonniers
cela pourrait être le début d'une
nouvelle ère
[Musique]
m
il va faire très chaud aujourd'hui à los
angeles
bon c'est quoi le programme aujourd'hui
à raison
comme tous les jours
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ma
chambre
chasse aux vampires
pognon
la chasse aux vampires c'est un business
je tranche des gorges
et j'encaisse
ça a changé depuis quitté fait jeter
comme une merde du syndicat je dois
trouver 10 400 kw à ma femme et ma fille
vont partir en floride pour changer ya
qu'eux qui peuvent allonger ce genre de
tubes
son dossier est un joyeux bordel
[Musique]
bottes lacées un homme neuf une dernière
chance c'est votre dernière carte
voilà du taf
vettel
des vampires bien d'essayer de me tuer
et en plus j'ai baissé dans mon plus
beau pantalon
se pisse dessus la première fois que
c'est vrai
non non moi non mais écoute toi
tu sais ce que je vois quand je vois un
vampire un gros paquet d'oseille
n'écoute pas ok je ravale est
prêt à dégainer
qu'est ce
les vampires disparu
c'est tout ce que les assassins
c'est pas hésitation dans ta tion de
révélation 1ère partie ça rien à voir
pourquoi tu connais par coeur les titres
de la saga twilight bugs et pourquoi tu
aimes pas révélation deuxième partie
c'est la conclusion idéale de toute la
saga twilight bienvenue dans le service
de jour pendant x ray
[Musique]
à tous les coups sa mort
faut que je vous raconte le truc de
dingue qui m'est arrivé c'est quoi cette
histoire digne à elle a dit qu en l'état
on savait pas c'est l'adn trouvé était
le vôtre ou celui de votre frère jumeau
j'ai pas de frère vas-y banon aussi si
j'avais un frère jumeau je le sens en
fait si j'en ai un le cauchemar
et c'est lui c'est ce voilà quoi il est
la politique dans le sang beaulieu sur
mon frère congrès nous l'apprendra y
sera très très chaud le pauvre apprendre
qu'on a un frère jumeau noir est ce que
ça peut juste attendre la fin de la
campagne foutez de ma gueule après on
peut peut-être sa logique ne sont pas de
ma gueule chauffeur auxiliaires anthony
enchanté
on peut couper mois s'ils sont pas c'est
pas détendu et quand je suis pas détendu
j'ai tendance à trop parler
très bien que c'est sympa notre un peu
de musique j'ai un truc à dire on est
frères un [ __ ]
toutefois la partenaires sont venus
alors
[Musique]
soit je suis ton frère sûr je suis une
maladie honteuse narbo mon faucheuse et
tout mais se rencontrer nos parents un
concert je vois le genre à musique
classique telus lui diminué une union
naquit klein qui la pub c'était une
fuite on sait le mieux dans ces minutes
c'est quoi ton histoire du genou l'a
écouté un frère jumeau et c'est grégoire
beaulieu c'est une dingue une
fatigue et lui
si tu continues comme ça tu vas santé
dans le mur qu'est-ce d'angoise c'est
impressionnant mais personne n'en meurt
il a subi un choc émotionnel a récemment
on reste calme je suis très calme waouh
moi ton cul
[Musique]
bah il a appris qu'il avait un frère
jumeau rapidement donné à la naissance
plus du moment je vois pas
mais dieu c'est compliqué
en tout cas moi dans l'histoire j'ai de
la chance pourquoi pas parce que j'avais
une chance sur deux d'être toi
on est à 600 kilomètres d'un sna
ça fait loin pour une simple fête
reconnaît le david on est perdu au tour
des essais mais non c'est ici je te dis
pas que je sois pas aussi stupide
c'était un accident s'est avancé devant
la voiture on voudrait surtout pas que
les policiers reviennent et qui se met à
nous poser des tas de questions franches
de l'appeler jo que tu es monté dans une
voiture avec un homme ivre ce qui fait
une complice ils accomplissent d'un
homme ivre depuis un bon moment
puisque tu comptes bouder tout le week
end où tu vas site de musée c'est pas un
crime de s'amuser du sein je suppose que
je pourrais faire un effort
c'est un art où il dit
est-ce qu'il a parlé d'argent non il
souhaite que vous rentriez avec eux pour
enterrer le garçon c'est la coutume dans
leur région
beaucoup de gens disparaissent il se
volatilise
[Musique]
vous avez fait quoi avec ces cas
tous les intérêts
ils n'ont pas juste de renverser et lui
ont roulé dessus
est même plus de deux fois comment ils
appellent ça dans votre pays j'ai écrasé
vous ne pouviez pas fuir nez vous cacher
ce que ça t'a traversé l'esprit richard
qui pourrait avoir des attentions
beaucoup plus sinistres que ce que tu
imagines
oui j'avais un mari est fait et toi
aussi
pourquoi avez vous accepté de venir ici
[Musique]
ne vous trompez pas
ressemble peut-être une petite fille
mais c'est bien une femme
hèle un talent exceptionnel pour
l'imposture
[Musique]
prête
comment tu t'appelles
à
[Musique]
tavis plus jamais prononcé ces mots
on peut commencer soufi vous êtes prête
revenons en arrière
où étiez vous avant
et encore avant
vous avez plonge encore à fond
vous pouvez aller plus loin
vous vous rendez compte de ce que c'est
que de ne rien se rappeler du tout
tout le monde me détends la personne
qu'ils croient que je suis à notre
nouvelle vie si ma vie écrit aussi
parfaite que ça pour presser voulu en
finir
écoutez sophie le temps de tourner la
page et venir mais je veux savoir ce qui
s'est vraiment passé ça nous l'avons
compris et nous croyons l'avoir compris
pc basés uniquement sur ce qu'on croit
savoir de ce qui s'est passé
et si je n'avais pas sauté
vous n'avez rien vu ou entendu de
curieux en sauvant ce jour là vous étiez
choqué ce que vous racontiez était
incohérent vous disiez qu'un homme vous
avez poussé du bateau est votre
véritable nom n'était pas celui sur
votre pièce d'identité
personne avec une vie parfaite comme la
tienne c'est rare qu'elles plongent d'un
ferry pour marie a menti sur son alibi
qu'au jour de l'accident tu commençais à
me souvenir de certaines choses
j'imagine que ça doit être frais membre
c'est dur d'ignorer les secrets de son
existence
on peut pas simplement faire semblant
d'être une nouvelle personne
et que le passé n'existe pas
[Musique]
alors tu te souviens vraiment d'horaires
ton mari il est parce que tu crois
pourquoi te mentir il commence à poser
des questions des cas je veux pas
répondre peut-être que je me trompe sur
toute la ligne
sophie qu'est ce que tu veux savoir rien
je reconstitue le puzzle ça fait
les hommes qui travaillent pour moi
doivent être capables de violence
pourquoi il faut qu'on mette le feu déjà
s'appelle envoyer un message
arnott vous fait confiance et la
confiance a beaucoup de valeur
aujourd'hui
qu'elle n'est pas seulement ton employé
c'est aussi 3 me
je veux vraiment le respect qui vient
avec ce travail c'est pas du respect
c'est de la peur désolé de te déranger
le qu est ce que tu pars je suis la
distraction
allons tuer ce témoin on s'en occupe
merde nous a repérés je vais
l'intercepter
on n'arrête pas le progrès
patron il ya peut-être de témoin
débarrassons nous de la fille
vous voulez quoi
en var coutume ans je te remets ma
démission
je vais te pour chercher c'est quoi ton
plan dans ce cas là
c'est toujours un tueur à gages et moi
je suis la police moi j'ai les armes
beaucoup d'armes
je vais ramener la policière à monsieur
seulement
hockey
il faut se débarrasser des deux peu
importe que ça coule doucement nokia
patron
[Musique]
j'ai appris une vérité et réfute avec
les criminels sont toujours leur pire
ennemi regarde moi
[Musique]
j'aurais bien du contenu bonjour mathieu
sarrazin bonjour bonjour ça va
[Musique]
tu changes ton corps tu restes avec moi
aujourd'hui je peux pas mon cas
je te tuer a procédé
[Musique]
tout le dossier constitué de faux plus
ou moins grossier comprend mat pourquoi
comtois mathieu qu'est ce qu'il leur a
fait d'avoir des nouvelles de ma fille
et aussi je veux voir et
ne prend pas d'urgence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
al
keystone xl à istres
[Musique]
pincez vous êtes la personne ne doit
savoir et russie la presse personne ne
m'écoute pas moi j'aime ça c'est pas mal
derrag l'heure n'est pas aux glissements
je ne vais pas mettre en péril nos
relations avec la russie pour vous
posiez hors de question d'approuver
l'opération clandestine pour faire
quitter le territoire
la seule solution c'est de vous rendre
aux autorités russes
mais je suis innocent bordel
souvenirs les plus marquants il me
viennent de séjour ou ma vie a changé
je suis marié à la plus célèbre
journaliste au monde et fils ou
complètement perdus ils ont besoin de
savoir la vérité j'élève deux
adolescentes et superman et j'essaie de
rendre cette planète plus sûres
quand tu fais des trucs de superman et
moi je vais faire mes trucs de loïs lane
si jamais quelqu'un découvre qui je suis
ça va tout changer
vraiment pas comme les autres
ford est devenu superman témoin suite
on va devoir surveiller de près ses
pouvoirs
nous avons assez de grip de vie de
concret l'armée
il se passe quelque chose de terrible
ici on trouvera des réponses simples
[Musique]
superman hello his votre nouvelle série
inédite marty à 21h10 sur tf1
je viens du futur
si vous ne m'écoutez pas
voilà ce qui va se passer
new bond street l'euro
sa centrale va exposer papa n'est pas de
faire croire que toutes les catastrophes
qui ont lieu dehors sont toutes de ma
faute si tu construis ta centrale voilà
ce qui va se passer
tous les 70 ans le nuage tue 50 % de la
population à chacun de ses passages je
vais bien drôle à
sacrifier mon père pour sauver le monde
c'est pas juste je suis sûr qu'il peut
changer
ses complices sont notre priorité
ces actions peuvent briser le continuum
espace temps
y
à de nouveaux types qui ont débarqué le
clodo disparu je suis perdue
3-2 sur mer
le compte à rebours se désinscrire
mi-temps et protéger le cours du temps
si on perd tout le monde perd
tout a une fin et le monde
vous inquiétez pas il n'y aura pas le
temps de me voir venir
[Musique]
tout s'est effacé ma mémoire est ce qui
s'est passé après
le matin très tôt j'ai reçu un appel de
l'hôpital tu avais été transporté tu
étais blessé je suis venu te voir je
suis passé dans la rue du restaurant il
y avait des fleurs et dessins d'enfants
découle un couloir dans lequel les
jeunes ont défilé
ce que vous pouvez vous asseoir ailleurs
selon mes parents et s
vous sous les marques
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites ici vous vous
êtes précipité dans les toilettes au
premier coup de feu vous n'avez pas
ouvert je n'ai pas fait ça
parakou soûlé de tout ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi voulez-vous s'ouvrir
je me retourne au musée où ils ont été
la dernière chose qu'ils ont
l'impression de leur dire au revoir
[Musique]
faut qu'on fasse on aurait dû faire ce
soir là
mais ça c'est dur et j'aurais préféré y
est on se prépare à tenter
[Musique]
bien sûr quelques sourires ça puisse
gêner
[Musique]
avant je ne demandez jamais si j'étais
aux
on
a retenu
deux griefs
vous
[Musique]
oui
chine sont mortes soit chez
[Musique]
les futures us mais parler
semaine
chic
[Musique]
au
brassage by day
m
et moi la faille
notre état d'esprit à cet instant
c'était qu'après avoir survécu à ce
terrible ouragan on pouvait survivre à
tout le reste
mais on avait tort
on a retrouvé quarante cinq cadavres sur
place
comment ça a pu arriver
je subi énormément de pression pour
mener une enquête sur ce qui s'est passé
durant cinq jours nous avons dû
affronter les pires conditions possibles
on va évacuer tous les patients de
l'hôpital on est des êtres dernier c'est
notre travail
vous n'abandonnez pas ici
[Musique]
on pourrait se montrer réaliste quant à
la situation
on ne peut rien faire d'autre part
notation
sp rendre ça le moins pénible possible
une minute de quoi on parle
ils m'ont demandé d'enquêter sur les
morts ou mémorial medical center un an
le bureau du procureur général concentre
son enquête sur vous
il suggère que la vie de plusieurs
patients a été écourté je me suis assuré
que ces patients ne souffrent pas
certaines personnes craignaient ce qui
se passait hors de l'hôpital mais moi
c'était le contraire
si vous aviez le choix entre soulager
les patients
leur accordons une mort rapide
les abandonner en les condamnant à une
mort lente
quel choix feriez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai fait qu aider les gens si tout
ce que j'ai fait